Reggie Miller called game one last night
between the Grizzlies and spurs with
Kevin Harlan they got game two tomorrow
night and reg also calling Warriors
rockets game three on thursday game four
Hawks Celtic Sunday on TNT and you're
busy how are you uh I'll have I want
your biggest lobster with stage Oh Dirk
and I what is really the best wine red
wine here in this establishment can we
have like three bottles oh hello Mei
rail I'm sorry I was just working on my
ordering from since I've got our three
didn't cover from Daniel feared or
reggie said man I'm gonna do that's what
I'm going to do to all right because
there's so many of us danette but I can
only take one of you guys to dinner with
me so now's the time to start sucking up
to uncle Reggie which one of you damn it
it's going to be my date when Daddy fear
or take the dinner so you can start like
with emails or pictures or however you
want to suck up to me to get to dinner
when our good friend Theodore we are
having steak and lobster and the best
red wine on the house um Big Daddy Kane
digital yeah i lost the Golden State bet
reg text me right as the game ended and
I said thank god you're not a big
drinker and he's I think you know yeah
but that night bus said you like what
did that but what did I say I think
something was champagne didn't you I
said I'm not a big drinker but that
night I will what a season though
seriously first of all we got to revert
back what a last night of the regular
season between the 73 wins of the
Warriors and Kobe being
60 okay you're flipping back and forth
I'm guessing I was okay Bri what were
you more interested in well we you got
the feeling the Golden State was going
to go they were gonna win 73 you had no
idea that Kobe was going to go for
solutely zero and as you're watching it
unfold I kept saying to myself is this
is it real is this really going on right
now because everyone especially any
professional athlete always want to go
out on top going out on top obviously is
winning a championship but do you want
to have your physical skills to play
well at your last game and to see Kobe
struggle all year he had a few great
games this year but over the last two
years it's been a struggle for the
Lakers obviously in the win column but
really for Kobe Bryant who was one of
the most competitive guys that I've ever
played against so to see him struggle
for the last two years on the court and
for one game put it all together it was
it was beautiful to watch but on the
flip side because I give Kobe Bryant all
the credit for that 60 game if you're
Utah are you kidding me seriously you
you were one game out from the eighth
spot are you serious you can't give up
60 okay I'm sorry reg can do could they
have double-teamed Kobe at any point
during the fourth quarter with that did
they feel like that was going to be rude
on Kobe Bryant you're not not rude but I
will say this look to score 60 points
and to shoot 50 tell deegaanka 250 time
at 28 to shoot 50 times people don't
understand the energy that it takes to
shoot 25 times to double that and shoot
50 times I mean that is amazing at age
37 I would I told people I needed a
massage after watching that game
seriously I needed to go to the steam
shower I was so sore for Kobe Bryant
that's different shell we even heard
from
Toby he might be on life support
seriously anyone heard from Kobe since
that game no I think he got up and
worked out the next morning according to
the lab at Sony Pictures I'm serious
suit might be on life I'm serious John
black they had a PR said that Kobe
worked out the next morning well just
like there's that Bigfoot video is there
really Bigfoot or not that's that's a
lot of shot I don't even know if you
ever had 13 a game reg Theodore 50 shots
60-point and I don't care of your plane
in a rec league it's hard to get 60
points in just a pickup game in an MBA
qualified game Utah gave up 60 points
Utah will forever be known as the
throwaway to Russell and Jordan holding
an extended and then 60 points seriously
that's what I will always think of the
Utah Jazz I a couple things here reg I
asked the damage would you rather watch
a close Celtics hawks game or a blowout
Warriors rockets game in the blowout
warriors game is still on the floor yes
yes it is a blowout yeah I would
definitely want to see the splash
brothers because it's it's the video
game element aspect of it that you're
watching because it's going to be crazy
shot it's going to be the
behind-the-back passes you know the ball
movement so it doesn't treat me the
close game because there's a little bit
more strategy and intention in that but
to see those guys go crazy from you know
the video game elevate of you know 15
threes between the two of them and the
passes I'll probably say a blowout
Warriors day all right I appreciate the
honesty now Chris Mannix esteemed NBA
reporter said that Kawhi Leonard is the
next Kobe Bryant well funny you say that
because when we had our coaches meeting
yesterday
Kevin Harlan and myself and we asked
Gregg Popovich who does Kawhi Leonard of
all the great players and Hall of Famers
who does Kawhi remind him hub and I was
thinking maybe he was going to say you
know Scottie Pippen though Scotty wasn't
to score that quiet is now but
defensively he they're somewhat long and
similar he said Kobe Bryant as well he
says the way that Kobe was able and if
you watch the mannerisms of their
fadeaways and the way they face up and
offensively go the ability to go get
their own shot because Gregg Popovich if
you look over the last 15 years of the
Spurs dynasty they've never had a player
like Kawhi Leonard where they would
isolate everything's been ball movement
if you look at the success this year has
been the only year they've gone to a 14
system in close games and given the ball
two colliding say go win the ball game
for us and he has that ability like Kobe
Bryant to look over the defense
one-on-one and make it move so even
Gregg Popovich is comparing him to Kobe
Bryant Stan Van Gundy had an interesting
quote he says that his team just has to
accept that LeBrons not going to get
called for offensive fouls fair
criticism from Stan Van Gundy planting
those Van Gundy's are good at that i
mean he's putting it out there for the
officials that are going to be
officiating this series look you're
going against you know one of the
greatest players to ever play the game
in LeBron James and I will say that it
wasn't LeBrons that was the problem last
night it was Kevin Love and Kyrie Irving
was fantastic all evening and they are
the one who put the imprint on that game
but if I'm Detroit I've got to feel good
going into Game two how we played and
performed on the big stage on the road
with a bunch of young guys we played
pretty well in
took them down the stretch we've got to
hold our composure if you're Reggie
Jackson you can't be getting a tea late
we made shots and Detroit is not known
to be a three-point shooter team and
they were on fire from downtown so
you've got to feel good as the success
that you had in Game one now you've just
got to be able to complete it and play
just a little bit better on the road to
get one of those road wins you have more
time wasn't do you have more common
wasn't the problem in Game one it was it
was his his sidekicks of the big three
do you have more confidence in the Cavs
winning it all or the Spurs winning at
all confident yeah oh I would go with
their three look it's the Cavs to lose
in the east in my opinion the Cavs are
coming out of the East but there's three
teams that will beat the cavs in the
finals and that's the Warriors of spurs
or okc okay she would be Cleveland in
the fund yeah yeah they're okay okc is a
very scary team if you're the Spurs in
that second round because right now
between Westbrook and Durant and how
they're playing and now you've got
Cantor who he probably won't win it but
a six event of the Year candidate
they're big Ibaka has found his game
this team is playing at a different
level that's a scary scary second-round
matchup for the third if you're Steve
Kerr gear s definite tonight if you're
Steve Kerr or general manager Bob Myers
that side of me would say yes because
then that would buy him you know a few
extra days before Game three that Kevin
and I are going to be calling a game on
Thursday but the basketball side of me
me at seventy-five eighty percent if I'm
step is still better than Patrick
Beverley and and Jason Terry you don't
ever want to mess up rhythm and I would
still want to be out there and playing
because I'm still going to be a threat
every time I touched the basketball and
I'm moving out there on the floor so the
basketball side
me says if I'm stuff I want to play
being practical as a coach or a GM and
looking ahead we're at home it's Game
two we just meet him by 26 we have
enough weapons at home to beat a number
18 I could see Steve Kerr sitting him
down and arresting him but the
basketball side of me wants to play yeah
I got a look at long haul and it's that
same ankle that he had surgery on I
can't take a chance if I feel like
there's you know I don't want him to go
out and favorite I don't want him to go
out less than a hundred percent or at
least in his mind think that way I don't
want you to play differently so i would
risk the Norse you've got to be
definitive on your answer you can't let
him come in and warm up go out there and
go through this you know and then come
back in and say it's not feeling right
if you're going to shut them down for
this game don't even let them warm up
have them come in get therapy you know
pregame let him get therapy after the
game that watch the game but don't let
them come in there and warm it up and be
on his ankle and go through them that
that's too much if you're going to sit
him for a game sit him let him get
therapy and then have them ready to go
in game 3 I saw where there was a
possibility at least it was floated that
that Kobe could maybe end up with TNT
with with Shaq and Charles and Kenny
could you swim on to the dark could you
see a studio analyst I read the same
thing I think it would be fantastic as
you know we're very free-flowing here at
Turner and Kobes knowledge of the game
he's never been one to hold his tongue
if you remember him and Charles kind of
got into it on the set one time when
Kobe was a guest I think it would be a
great addition has he been offered the
opportunity to be there for the
postseason with TNT I have no idea I i
do not know that's above my pay grade
are you lying to me right now wrench I
have not why would I ever lie to you
have I always been truthful with you yes
that's above my pay grade I have no idea
I read what you read okay don't get
short with your answers cut but but if
you're them
mama come on over to the dark side B
we're waiting on you if if I had that
team on could you guys win a playoff
game if I had you Kenny Charles Shaq
Ernie and chris webber and Kobe yeah you
guys here are going yeah online soma and
we forgot 3d Dennis Scott coming off the
bench we would have bones brent Barry
coming off the bench that's our roster
yes yeah which which which NBA team can
be one of these out of the 16 teams in
the playoffs we would be one of those
teams who is that fair enough yeah but
tell me who you'd be calling their King
tomorrow I don't want to throw
underneath the bus they don't have all
this later but without Conley and
without Gasol I think we could give the
Grizzlies a run right now don't you
think that roster you just like you just
probably probably now I are you saying
win the series or win a game you said
win a game right yeah but we could win a
game okay so you're talking about maybe
theory oh yeah you I don't know look I'm
50 Charles is 50 what three kidneys 50
sack is 40 what 342 Webber's 40 dr.
Webber is 43 FL roster I don't know
maybe we could with this hold on keep
going I gotta stretch out hey I wouldn't
mind seeing that dude I saw you shoot in
Houston and it never leaves it never
leaves man it never leaves that's the
last thing to leave you now if you're
out you're lucky it down and and take in
front of Matt Barnes and Tony Allen and
that's a different that's that's a
little bit different Chauncey Billups if
I don't know if you ever heard this
story but i'll leave you with this
chauncey billups was with us in houston
and i said your fur
running with Michael Jordan he said I
was with the Celtics and I'm a rookie
and I'm standing at the top of the key
during a free throw and I'm there with
Ron Mercer and he's on one side i'm on
the other and we just stared at Jordan
and Jordan caught us staring and then
yelled at us for staring at him at the
top of the key to him free he said we
got busted man we were just staring go
that's Jordan man like what are you
staring at rook oh that's like Mike oh
that's good that's good I have fun
tonight well no you you're off tonight
i'm off tonight well i'm going tomorrow
what will you do tonight oh it's Fiesta
here in San Antonio though it is raining
a lot of the festivities have been
canceled but it's the big parade and
even down here for for San Antonio in
the riverwalk so it's BS nah I behaved
and and I'm gonna take out a bank loan
to pay off the Golden State Warriors bet
so I'll be back in LA in May so which
that should it be nepali if it fritzy is
it big loving beaten hey next time
you're out there to do sports jeopardy
and all the crew is with you I will make
my decision gentlemen okay and don't be
afraid to have Mark Jackson you and
somebody else play sports jeopardy
unless you're afraid the NBA edition of
sports jeopardy you and arc Jackson that
would be we would be awesome but who's
the third guy I'm letting you pick the
third guy and you do sports jeopardy
will do NBA will do college basketball
and NBA I'm letting got it I'm letting
you pick the third guy and it's you
against Mark Jackson bragging rights for
eternity on the sports jeopardy set
maybe Alex Trebek even stopped by old I
am told I am sold I will get a hold of
my good friend Mark Jackson and we will
come up with a third maybe Kobe
that's good see is that doing anything
now he's on life support you would be
the like you or there would be Kobe and
trivia I don't know yeah you've always a
worldly guy smart guy you would you
would knowing how competitive you are
not like we know the answer is going in
no no you don't know the answer is going
in I know that's okay we don't know what
Kobe knows Kobe's a smart guy okay all
right well that's your third you can
pick whoever you want you want bill
simmons in there whoever you want you
pick the guy you pick your third all
right you're the best viewed or anybody
I love you much that's so Reggie
Aloysius Miller the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience